- I have revised my prediction.
I'm going to beat Gary Vaynerchuk
to one million subscribers
and maybe even Tai Lopez too.
What's up Believe Nation?
It's Evan, my one word is
believe and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves
and my sincere hope
is that if you see in
you what I see in you,
you'll be able to change the planet.
Now, I'm a little bit sick today.
Just recovering from a really
bad stretch of constant fever.
So I'm excited to be back.
And I started this series
about how to get one million subscribers
to document my journey along the way.
I think I started this series
when I had about 550,000 subscribers.
Last video, I had 775 subscribers
and now we're well over 800.
And the goal was really
to kind of show you
what I'm doing to build my channel.
How to get 40 to 50,000
subscribers a month and grow
and try to build a million
subscriber channel.
And you guys could hopefully learn
through that process as well
if your goal is to build a
successful YouTube channel.
So today I'm going to
compare my channel again
to Gary Vaynerchuk and
now, also to Tai Lopez.
A little bit of background,
Gary's friend of the channel.
He's interviewed on the channel.
I've collaborated with
him for a number of years
way back before I even
had a YouTube channel.
I'm sure Gary doesn't really care
about who hits one
million subscribers first.
It's just a fun little competition.
It's nice having someone
to go ahead to head with.
Tai, I don't really know.
We did a top 10 on him.
I'm not super familiar with his channel
but I'm going to to dive into
some of the details today
and we'll see what we can uncover.
Okay, so back in April,
I made a video saying that Gary Vaynerchuk
was going to pass me on YouTube
and I'd have to make a
video in a few months
to say, Gary Vee passed me.
And now he's going to pass me.
You look at the curve,
he's catching up and he's
on the path to beat me.
And so, I'm going to be making a video
in a couple months saying,
Gary's ahead of me and I'm
now not the number one channel
for entrepreneurs out there in the world.
And I got off my game, it's great.
Well, fast forward to August,
he hasn't passed me yet
and I don't think it's going
to happen anytime soon.
Let me show you why.
Okay, so here's a comparison of my channel
versus Gary Vaynerchuk on Social Blade
and if we go down to look at
the head by head comparison,
as you can see at the very start,
so I'm the red line, he's the blue line.
If this goes leaving before,
Gary had a bigger audience than I did
and then I passed by him and
then there's this huge gap
that started to open up, right?
Huge gap of, what?
About a hundred thousand or so?
What do we add here?
Let's look at this.
I was 424 used 334, so you
know 90,000 subscribers,
huge gap, big gap, big gap
and then, he starts to
post two videos a day,
three videos a day and
he starts catching up.
He starts closing that gap.
Closing that gap, closing
that gap to the point here
which is what?
June.
So I said in April that
in a couple months,
that he would pass me, it's pretty close.
In June, he's 6,000 behind,
5,000 behind, 6,000 behind.
He's really narrowing
that gap to 5,000 behind.
He got within 5,000 and
now look what's happening.
The gap is getting bigger again
to the point where now, as
we're recording this video,
he's at 791 I'm at 817 so that's what?
26,000 gap and getting bigger.
More important is like
he's kind of leveling off
and I'm going up.
So there's two main reasons
why this is happening
and a short term thing
that's negatively impacting Gary's channel
that I want to talk to you about.
So the first thing I look at
is the frequency of
upload on Gary's channel.
One of the main reasons why
he was able to catch up to me
was because he was making
two to three videos a day
and he slowed down.
He slowed down and is what YouTube wants.
YouTube wants people who are
making consistent content.
Now, we've slowed down to one a day
which isn't that bad
but it's not two a day
and there's a big gap
between going a couple
times a week to once a day
but there's still a gap
between one and two a day
and Gary is falling down right now.
Maybe it's a summer thing,
maybe that's another reason for doing it,
maybe there's people on his
team that are shuffling around
but if we look at how many
videos are a week old,
one, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
Seven videos last week.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
Seven videos a week before.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven,
eight videos the week before.
He's down to a video day
and that's still really, really good
with you to dug rhythm
but it's not two a day
and so it's going to slow his growth
compared to someone who's
making more consistent content.
Reason number two is
what I said back in April
about me needing to up my game.
It's really, really important
to look at your YouTube channel
and every individual series
and if they are performing for you or not.
So as an example if I
pull up Gary's channel,
he's got a lot of different series, right?
He's got his AskGaryVee calling show
or however he's doing it.
Episode 259, episode 261, episode 260.
He's got his DailyVee's.
That happened on a consistent basis.
This is a daily vlog show so,
I know it was five times a week typically.
He has this fireside chats,
he's got random interviews that happened.
And so, he's got this
mishmash of different series
and what's really important to look at
are these series
performing for you or not?
I want to show you something
I've never shown people before.
This is how I run my YouTube channel.
This is real data with the
names of the series removed.
And so what's really important
here is looking for us
at two key metrics, watch
time and subscribers.
Every series that we put out is measured
according to watch time and subscribers.
Watch time because that's what
YouTube really cares about.
If you are generally a lot
of watch time on your videos,
you're going to get more attention
from YouTube and subscribers
because I want my series
to benefit the channel.
Not that my channel has lots a watch time
but I want subscribers to be coming to it.
So this is one series,
this is another series,
this is another series
and every month we look at the
data to see how it's going.
And I only look at the data for that month
because a video that did
well really a long time ago,
our Steve Jobs Top 10 Rule For
Success, four million views,
I don't want that corrupting
kind of my new data.
I want to know that my top 10
series is still performing well,
that if I put up a new top
10, it's still performing well
and that we're not just
relying on the old stuff.
And so as an example,
this is a series that we're
looking at today here.
This is it.
This is the path to one million.
In our first video against Eric Thomas,
it generated 13,000 minutes of watch time
and eight subscribers in the month.
Now, since that month
is probably generated a
little bit more for us.
But again, in that one month,
the second was Gary Vee,
that one did better, 55,000
watch time, 59 new subscribers.
The next one was Grant Cardone.
27,000 watch time, 13 new subscribers
and then the most recent
one that we did before this,
we don't have full data on
yet so it's not in here.
But that's how well the series does.
So I know if I'm putting out a video,
okay it's going to generate
between 13 and 55,000
minutes of watch time
so that's going to give me between
eight and 59 new subscribers
and I want to think, okay, if
that's going to be a daily series,
if I was doing this
more than once a month,
I'd have to optimize that 'cause
these numbers are not good
compared to some of these
other numbers, right?
If a series here is generating
285 minutes of watch time
and this one only is 27,000, I'm thinking,
I don't want to keep this anymore
or I need to make this better.
And so the things that's really
helped my channel recently
is one, looking at underperforming series
and canceling them.
So you see blank spots here
because those are canceled
series that we destroyed.
All of these blank spots
were canceled series that we destroyed.
So we have lots of data for
all these ones as we kept them
and this one was a relatively new one
and all these are the
ones have been canceled.
So it's underperforming, it goes.
Some of these are new tests.
So these are bubble series.
When I say on the video
that I'm not sure if we're going
to keep this series or not,
it's legit, it's true.
We may not keep it or not.
Right now, whatever series this is
to generate 37,000 minutes of watch time
and only to new subscribers,
that's not cutting it for us.
So, in our test series, we'll do three,
I'll do three versions of something.
We'll see we get enough data on it.
See if we can move that number up
and if we can, we keep it
and if we don't, we kill it.
So why has my channel grown recently?
What is attribute to the new spike?
Let me show you on this site here.
So one was killing off the bad series,
two, this, when it's purple like that,
that represents the best series
for subscriber growth in the month.
So you can see the dates here.
So from June to July as an example,
this series, this series
and these three series
all have the highest subscriber growth.
Look at this series here.
This series had a history
of underperforming.
8,000, 12,000, 9,000, 9,000,
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh,
highest is 22, not bad
Boom!
77,000 minutes of watch time.
Subscribers, two, three, two,
two, one, 36 subscribers.
This is per video.
So 36 new subscribers for every video
in this series that I'm doing.
Now, if this is a once a month series,
that's not that big a deal.
If that's a once a day series,
that's a much bigger deal.
Like our Top 10 series
comes out five times a week.
If I could do fives times,
36, that's a good number.
Right?
So this series did really well
and so what we're doing
is look at this series,
okay, how do we tweak it?
How do we make it better?
How do we improve it?
Because we're looking at watch
time and subscriber growth.
Will mean a few changes, bam!
A big growth.
Same thing with this series here.
55,000 minutes of watch time.
That's a decent series.
Nine subscribers per video in
the first month, decent series
but look what happened.
We made some tweaks and changes.
From 55 to 448, from 9
subscribers to 378 per video
that we put up in that series.
This one also had a big jump.
95,000 to 190,000,
average, doubling the
watch minutes per video
and and more than
doubling the subscribers.
So it might be kind of a
confusing graph to look at
and I don't blame you
and YouTube doesn't really
give you those tools built-in.
We have to kind of make custom reports
and sift through the data.
But that's what my team and
I look at every single month.
We want to make sure that every
single series is performing
and if it's not, then there's a reason.
Right?
And I've talked about this
on previous series as before.
If there's a reason to have a video
that is going to underperform, that's okay
but you know that there's
a reason for it, right?
So an example, if you're
going to make a sales pitch.
If I'm going to come on
in sell my book, right?
Buy this book, it's the
greatest book ever, right?
Some of you guys will love that
but it won't be the
highest video on my channel
and may even lead to
negative subscriber growth.
That's okay because it's serving
a different purpose, right?
I'm serving a business purpose.
So whenever you do a
sales pitch kind of video,
you can expect your numbers to tank
and feeling you lose some subscribers.
That's okay because you're generating
some revenue from it, right?
But it's the the other
ones are the killer.
It's the ones that you think
are helping you grow your channel
but are actually hurting you
but if you can find ways
to either adjust or tweak
that series or kill them off,
your channel really start to take off.
Now the third thing is going
to hurt Gary in this race
that he doesn't know about
is that he's going away.
He is away right now.
He is not making videos and
well-deserved family vacation.
You'll need to time
off and I applaud that.
It becomes a challenge especially
for a vlogger to go away.
For you guys who are vloggers,
unless you're vlogging your vacation
and then it might be some amusing content,
some new content out of your city
but in general, it's hard to get time off
because the content is so dependent on you
and showing your life.
The other stuff you could
have done in advance.
It could have lined up.
AskGaryVee, five shows,
film them all in one day
and then release them over time.
What happened last year
and what's probably
going to happen this year
was just his team did a
mishmash of some old stuff,
couple minute clips, put them together
that weren't very good
and as a fan of the channel,
a fan of Gary's channel,
I was like, okay when's Gary coming back?
I want some new stuff,
I want the real deal.
And maybe his team is much
better this year, who knows?
He's put a lot more time
into building his team
and so we'll see what happens.
I just going to take a look on his channel
'cause he just recently ran away.
Let's see.
So this is Gary's channel.
So here it is,
signing off for a month
then they show some ad
tech conference he did.
Great, a Keynote, perfect
and then, see, this is the stuff
that will kill your channel.
This two-minute, two-minute,
at least he's posting consistently,
at least it's still going on
but YouTube right now,
from an algorithm perspective,
does not want to see these short videos.
This will kill the channel,
these will get some decent views
but will have terrible watch time
and will start to drag down the channel
and it's going to make it harder for Gary
when it does come back to make it awesome.
Now, a lot of people say so what?
August is a slow time, people go away.
It's okay for your chance to drop down.
August doesn't have to be a slow month.
August has been a great
month for me so far
and was last year too.
Let's look at the data.
So this is the Social
Blade for my account.
If I go down to see August,
you know August last year
was better than my July
and better than my June and
was the same as my September
and the same as my October almost.
Fast forward to August now,
oh, we can't see 'cause
it's not done yet but look,
like July was my best month ever.
July was my best month ever with growth,
with subscriber growth, with views
and August, I'm recording
this August 15th?
Look at the August numbers already.
Last 30 days,
so 46,000 subscribers last 30 days
and July was 44 so it's
already, it's a record month.
It's a record month already in August
and June is a record month.
So it doesn't have to be a slowdown.
Remember what happened in July.
July was a record month for me,
despite almost all the
videos having terrible sound.
You guys killed me for
the sound on the videos.
Good morning Believe Nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe and
I believe that entrepreneurs
will solve all of the
world's major problems.
You killed me on the
sound and rightfully so.
Like I have standards,
I want to produce good
quality stuff for you.
That's not acceptable
to have really bad sound
but despite having
really poor sound, right?
Which you think make a worse video
but consistently keeping to
what the YouTube algorithm wants
and making the three videos a day,
we had our best month ever.
We had the worst sound ever
and we had our best month ever.
Now we fixed the sound,
I'm on track for an even better
month ever and it's August.
And so it's a tip not just
for YouTube but in business.
While your competition is
away on vacation and sleeping
and taking time off and it's a slow time,
that's the time when you hustle.
That's the time when you can get to work
and do amazing things.
I used to hate August and
December in general in my business
because people wouldn't
return phone calls,
you couldn't get business done
and I realized this is my time to plan.
This is my time to really hustle and grind
so that when September does come around,
I'm going to be firing on all cylinders.
I'm going to be way
ahead of everybody else.
Now, luckily with YouTube,
you can still have an amazing August.
Not have to wait for anything.
So whenever you see your
competition going to sleep,
that's your chance to
attack and get ahead.
So that's what happened
with me versus Gary Vee.
Our graphs are certainly go apart.
It's going to get even bigger.
He's going to be away
for the next little bit.
Gary's going to have to come
back and just absolutely destroy
and get back to really
making two videos a day here
if you want to win, if you want
to get to that million first.
Two videos of amazing Gary
Vee content every single day.
- When I come back in September,
we're going to come with
some real fire on YouTube
so you do get ready.
I'm going to spend this
time, me and that team,
we're going to spend some
time to really come back
with a 4.0 version of
what we're doing here.
- Alright, let's get to Tai Lopez now.
People has been asking about Tai.
They wanted my thoughts on his channel.
Any breakdown and advice I could offer.
So let's look at Tai's channel.
Now at the top of the show,
I said I might beat Tai Lopez
to one million subscribers.
You go to the Social Blade
and you see that he's
at 989,000 subscribers.
You think, well how are you
going to beat Tai to one million
when he's already at 989.
Tai runs his YouTube
channel a lot differently
than most people and so this is why.
Let's look down, you
look at his Social Blade,
he is not really growing.
Right, the past week
it's been all negative
except for today where he
had a little bit of growth.
And if you look at the
growth history here,
this is his views and this is his subs.
Tai doesn't get his
subscribers from his content.
Tai gets his subscribers
from his advertising.
And so when Tai decides
to just produce content,
he actually loses subscribers.
When Tai decides to advertise
a lot, he gain subscribers
and so he obviously has a
way to be able to make money
from his channel, right?
It funnels to his various
courses and programs
and I don't know anything
about those programs
so I can't recommend them
or not but it's working.
It's making money from it and it's working
so he's going to continue doing it.
So let's look at the
history of his channel.
So he's fooling around here,
he's got a million views a
month, a million views a month
and then boom!
What month is this?
September 2015, 95.73 million views.
This, ladies and gentlemen,
is the here in my garage campaign, right?
If you look at the here in my garage ad,
this is when it was launched
and so he went from one to 95
million views that he bought.
So he basically bought 95 million views.
Now if we go down to his subscribers,
you see that it led to a nice chunk
of new subscribers, right?
It said 59,000, 64,000 subscribers.
So he bought a chunk of subscribers
but he wasn't getting
that many more subscribers
from that video compared
to what he had before.
To go from 59, 64, down to 20,000.
So he spent how much money
to buy 95 million views
to get an extra 35, 40,000 subscribers?
But I guess it worked out for him, right?
Everybody has seen that commercial
and he was able to funnel them
into different advertising
courses for himself.
What's really interesting
is as we fast forward down to here,
you look at January 2017,
he had this huge surge in subscribers.
He jumps two hundred and
15,000 new subscribers
with almost no huge
growth here on his views.
He wasn't spending the money
on his views up here anymore.
So he spend in different ways.
Either it's off platform,
spending on Instagram
or Facebook ads or is
looking at pre-roll ads
that don't count towards
the view count of the video.
So it's not really leading
to a lot of new views
on his channel that's lead into a lot
of new subscribers for him.
And so you can see the once
he shuts off his advertising,
it just falls back down.
So it's really hard to predict
what's going to happen.
How do you go from a channel
that have a 115,000 new
subscribers in January
down to having 400 new
subscribers six months later?
How do you have a channel
that is losing subscribers on most days,
just from organic video?
It's really up to Tai.
When Tai want to spend
money in advertising,
his channel's going to
explode and when he doesn't
then the channel is going to sure to sink.
And so it's just a different model
than what most YouTubers do.
We typically grow to the
content that we create
and Tai has found his
own unique place of stand
that through advertising,
can build his own little empire off of it.
So those are my quick thoughts.
Me versus Gary Vee vs Tai Lopez.
We'll see who hits one million first
between the three of us, I'm excited.
It's all fun anyway, there's
no real stakes on the line
but it's nice to see have
a little bit of competition
as we all grow together
to try to help the entrepreneur community.
Now let me hand up some questions
and see what you got from last episode.
The most liked comment
from last month's video
from C.MD.AMEEN SOHAIL.
You don't have million subscribes.
Triple exclamation point.
That's a fantastic point.
I'm glad that that's what
you took at the last video.
It's really interesting
to see what people take
away from content.
Like are you the kind of person who finds
the truth and things or just finds
one little kind of detail to pick out
and just be a naysayer all the time.
I acknowledge in every series
that this is about the path
to getting to a million subscribers.
And also, the meaning of the
point of that last video,
how's that 775,000 subscribers?
What are you at C.MD.AMEEN SOHAIL?
Zero, zero subscribers.
So someone who is 77.5% along the way
that hitting a pretty big goal,
maybe there's still something
you can learn from them
and not just shut down.
Next, zGhostBlood_.
Not being a hater but Grant Cardone say
don't get advice for someone
who never get it yet.
It's the same thing, I think
it's the same comment, right?
Well first of all, go watch
the Grant Cardone video
because Grant Cardone
said that everybody
should listen his advice.
Grant Cardone said,
thanks Evan, great job and great content.
Let's do a podcast on this.
This is how you add value, folks.
Watch what Evan is doing here.
All caps, smart.
So zGhostBlood_, up to you man.
You could focus on the fact
that I'm not had a million subscribers yet
or you can actually
listen to Grant Cardone
'cause Grant gets it
that there's good advice in the videos
because it's way ahead of where you're at
if this is your goal or not.
Alright, moving on.
SouLoveLee, thank you for not putting
any background music on this video.
You're welcome.
Mihlovil, my prediction
for Evan's channel,
one million subscribers on the
25th of October, 2017, bam!
That's fast, that's fast.
Social blade has me, let me see.
So if you go to future projections here
to show you when they think
you're going to hit it,
you go subscriber milestones.
Social Blade thinks I'm going
to hit a million in 118 days.
December 12th, December 11th.
December 11th would be an
early Christmas present for me.
But I would love it to
be October 25th Mihlovil.
Let's make that happen, that'd be great.
Next up, Practical Psychology.
Hey Evan, something I've
been thinking about.
Instead of two to three videos a week
or even 1 video a week,
I've been thinking about
stockpiling some videos
and posting them all in November, December
for 50 for 60 videos in
a row, your thoughts?
The algorithm could change by then,
and I also wouldn't get instant feedback
but daily videos for 60
days on an animation channel
with high viewer retention
would be some amazing data.
I like it.
I would only say like,
don't stop doing what
you're doing right now
and and don't stop it in December.
Build the machine.
Just think about what do I need to do
to make an animation
video every single day.
I can't make a video myself.
When I was doing everything
myself, I could do one a week.
Just the editing took way too long
and the research took way too long.
Get in front of the camera and talking,
I could do kind of this
kind of video every day
but the videos that I wanted to make,
I couldn't do every day.
So I built a team.
So if you're making animation videos,
we're thinking, what's
your key role in it?
Are you animating?
Are you doing the story behind you?
Are you're doing the researching?
Are you doing the titling?
Maybe right now, you're doing everything
and start to think,
what is the most time-consuming thing
that is involved in your channel
that you don't want to do?
And then find someone to help you do that.
As soon as I found an
editor for my channel,
I was able to go to one video a day.
It made a world of difference.
So that's what you need to find.
Next up, Simarchy.
Can uploading daily or even
twice daily actually hurt you?
Sometimes I wonder if I'm
pumping out too much content
that my subscribers can't keep up.
I currently post one
times a day and livestream
one to three times a week.
For the record, I'm a gaming channel
centered around one franchise, The Sims.
I'm debating whether I
should take it down a notch,
but from your advice, you're
saying I should double it.
Just curious if can hurt some channels
or if it's always better to post more?
So, it's always better to
post more if it's good.
That's the tough part.
Anybody can just throw up
two videos a day or three videos a day.
Even when I was posting
the videos with poor sound
back in July.
They were still good
but when I showed you my series, right?
In that Excel chart or Google Docs,
we kill series all the time.
The ones that aren't
performing well, we kill.
And so we're paying really close attention
to is this series that I'm
putting out working or not?
Other things to keep in mind.
Don't expect your audience to keep up.
Stop worrying about your audience
watching every single video.
It's not going to happen.
I don't care if you guys watch
every video on my channel.
I don't need you to watch
I don't want you to watch
every video on my channel.
I want you to watch a video,
watch the ones that mean something to you
and then go do something about it.
And so we'll be looking at,
okay it does not matter to me
if my subscribers watch
every video that I have
as long as every video
is leading to growth
and is successful.
The other thing live stream
is its own algorithm.
Live stream is a whole different beast.
And so what really
happens in the live stream
is you get a lot of live
attention right away
but the replay value is really low.
You'll find that the live
videos are not watched much
after the fact.
Unless you're really
promoting them somehow,
they don't live for very long.
And so, if you're doing one post a day
and live streaming one
to three times a week,
I wouldn't count the live streams, really
as posts, as videos.
I'd be looking at making sure
that you're posting
one quality video a day
and if you have a live stream,
that's a great extra piece of content.
I'd make sure the live
streams aren't hurting you
because the live streams
are hurting my channel.
If I have a big name
that came on my channel
then it would help the channel.
But if I had someone who's
never been on camera before.
I had somebody that people
had no idea who they were.
It would actually lead
to negative subscribers
and this is why I
started a second channel,
Evan Carmichael Live for
any of the live stuff
that isn't with a well-known personality.
So I'm just again, look in your data.
Look at analytics.
Use the same metrics that I gave you.
Watch time per series,
subscriber growth per series.
If you can look at those videos a day,
are they all the exact
same video each time?
Can you have different themes?
And then within each theme,
which themes are forming
well with watch time
and subscriber growth
and which things aren't.
Kill off the ones that aren't doing well
and the live streams too.
Is it leading to watch
time for your channel?
Is a leading subscriber growth?
So the two most important metrics.
I'd be looking at more
content that is quality.
I would make five videos a day if I could.
I just can't.
I can't make it quality.
I could throw up five videos a day.
I would lose a bunch of people
because the three videos
I'm making are really good
but the fourth wouldn't be as good
and the fifth wouldn't be as good.
So that's a challenge
but if I could find a way
to make five really good
videos a day, I'll do it.
Jay Her, I found out about your channel
because of Charisma On Command.
Subscribed because your videos
are inspiring for my mind
towards increasing my clientele.
I really like your
attitude about business.
Thank you for that Jay Her.
Charlie is awesome from
Charisma On Command
and I'm glad you're here.
Welcome to Believe Nation.
ChartYourTrade, in one of
your videos you debunked
that no video should be
greater than six minutes long.
My question is what do you
think the minimum length
of a video should be?
Right now, if you want to do
well with YouTube's algorithm,
you want to be looking at 10 to 12 minutes
long video at least.
That's what they want.
That's I want to go to Gary's channel
and see what it's doing for
his strategy when he's away
and they're posting these
two, three minute videos.
It's going to hurt his channel.
Even if it's good stuff.
Like, it has to be,
it's not that no two-minute
video can do well.
You can go to the trending time
and see one really short video
but it used to be fill.
Like, YouTube trending used
to always be this short
little bloopers, little
fails, cute cat videos,
30-second recording, 59-second recording
to trying to get it under one
minute as much as possible
because people have short attention spans.
This has changed.
It's not what YouTube wants to promote.
They want to promote watch time.
And so, if a video,
even my six-minute
video that was too long,
now, I would want to make it 10 minutes.
The video that's done two
million views plus for me now
did well in an environment
where shorter videos were rewarded more.
Now, you want to be in
the 10 to 12 minute range
per video, ideally.
You can win again if it's shorter
but you're just playing
against the algorithm.
It has to be so insanely
overwhelmingly good
that it busts through the algorithm.
You could still win a race barefoot
but why not wear running shoes, right?
So I'd be looking at 10 to 12 minutes.
Next up, Christ Centered Ironworks.
Hey Evan, I've been watching
your videos for a while now,
ever since hearing about
you from Roberto Blake.
Awesome, welcome aboard.
Between the two of you,
your advice has helped me grow my channel
from 2,500 subs to 4600
subs in the last two months
by applying your teachings,
specifically we started
posting two times a day.
Hmm, imagine that.
So you he almost doubled
this channel in two months
by posting twice a day.
And my views went from
2,500 a day to 6,500 a day.
At first glance this might
not seem like huge growth
for some channels but I
am an artist blacksmith.
I have a very small niche
channel so it is huge to me.
Thank you for all you're doing on YouTube.
Hope this finds you well, God bless.
So this is the difference, guys.
So many of you are not even trying it.
There's a chunk of you who just say,
oh this guy hasn't hit
a million subscribers
so I'm just going to discount
everything that he's saying.
Perfect.
There's a whole other
chunk who'll find out
some other reason to discount
everything I'm saying.
Great.
Then there's going to be a
chunk of you who will say,
well I can't do that.
Find all the reasons why
this strategy stupid,
it's not going to work, it's
not for me, I can't do it,
buh-buh-buh-bah.
Excuses, excuses, reasons,
buh-buh-buh-bah, great.
Then you're going to have the small few
and these are the guys I
actually making this video for.
The small few to say,
huh, that's interesting.
How about I give it a shot?
You get this guy
who doubles his channel,
almost triples the views in
two months just by trying.
Just by going to two a day.
So many people are so
quick to discount an idea
without even trying it.
I'm telling you, this is
helping that will work for you
even if you are less talented
than the people above you.
My channel continued to grow
despite all those sound issues
with our best month ever
because we're playing
to YouTube's algorithm.
This is what YouTube's wants right now.
Again, 2018 may be
different, probably will be.
This is what's working right now
and it behooves you to
actually just give it a shot.
Just how about you try it
before you start hating on it
or just rejecting it flat out.
Next up, Ryan Bishop.
Hey, Evan, quick question.
Celebrity endorsements and collaborations.
How did you make contact?
Did you message 50 Cent and he replied?
Or you made the video and you
just hoped he would see it?
So for most of these,
it's starting to change a little now
but for most of them,
I never make contact.
But it also didn't surprise
me that they would share it.
I would always make
something that I'm proud of
and that if they saw it,
they would be proud of it.
So when we made the 50 Cent video,
before we press publish,
it's if 50 saw this,
would he be proud of it?
Would he want to show it off?
'Cause we're always trying to put people,
not necessarily just put
them in a positive light
but we want to share their best knowledge,
the best things that they got to say.
We've sifted through hours and
hours and hours of research,
of interviews that they've done
that pulled together the 10
nuggets that they've said
over the course of their career.
And so it's a tribute
to them and their advice
and their wisdom.
And so I never reached
out to 50 Cent to say,
hey, can you share this?
But it didn't surprise
me, never surprise me ever
when any of these people
share their videos
because it was made that way,
with intention that if they saw it,
they would want to share it.
Next up, Valerie.
Wow, Evan, thank you for
confirming what I knew to be true.
Great quality content daily.
Easier said than done.
That's true.
What hacks, if any, can you offer
about how to accomplish two
great quality videos daily.
I've heard about using batching.
What other tips, tricks,
tools of the trade
work creating daily quality content?
Also, do a lot of live
streams on my channel
and shocked to find out from you here
that is not the best.
Thank you again
and I'm one to take action
on what you shared here.
I love it Valerie, yes!
I love it.
Okay so, tricks to creating content daily.
Batching is definitely important.
So batching is basically taking
the tasks that you're doing repeatedly
and crunching them into one.
So for me, I used to film every Wednesday
and now I film once a
week for the most part.
Sorry, once a month for the
most part on a Wednesday.
That's why when my sound went out,
it impacted so many videos
because the sound was out
for pretty much the entire
recording day and so,
every Entpresso, every
top 10, every mentor me
is the same issue with the sound
and then when I filmed
it again the next month,
everything was fixed.
So now the new ones coming
out have better audio.
So I definitely be looking at
batching the recording time,
batching the researching.
So, think about your typical process.
If it's like research and
then record and then edit.
If I wanted to make two videos a day,
I'd be trying to think
about how do I record
those 14 videos in one day.
So I've been looking at
recording in one day.
To get that done,
how much research do I need to do before?
So do you need one day research?
You need to two days of research?
Three days of research?
Do you need to have somebody
help you with the research?
Then in the post, in editing,
this is what it becomes insanity.
The editing is just a crazy long process.
How much time you need?
And I'd be looking at how do I
bring on somebody to help me.
So batching first then building a team
underneath is going to help me.
Whether that is somebody who you hire,
whether you go to some place like Upwork
and hire a part-time editor to assist you.
Whether that's a friend who
volunteers and contributes,
a family member,
a client we can maybe
exchange services with
if they do the editing for your channel
and you help them with
whatever product or service
that you're selling.
Building a team becomes paramount.
I could not do this without my team.
We have eight people
who work on the YouTube
side of things for me.
That's how I make three videos a day.
I've two and a half editors on my team.
I have a person whose sole job
is to go out and do research.
People in the comments,
a cameraman obviously.
So building a team is
going to be super important
to your process
and then I've been
thinking about new series.
What kind of consistent new content
can you come up with on a regular basis
that doesn't require
in the moment thinking?
Because you're thinking,
oh, what's my video going to be about?
I have to record it today.
It's probably not going to
be super high quality stuff.
But if you're in advance thinking,
okay, I need to come up
with three new series
for the next month.
That's going to come out,
what am I going to do?
What's am I series going to be?
What am I interested in?
How I'm I going to document that?
And then paying attention to each series
and see if it's working.
Like this is just about
how to create the content
then you got to make sure the
content is working, right?
It's got to be delivering
and performing for you.
The comment about the live streams,
it's just unfortunate,
I love live streaming.
I love live streaming
because it's so great to
interact with the fans,
with you guys, with the audience.
It's just how YouTube works,
they give you a big boost but
the replay value isn't great
and so if you're really good,
like if you really
wanted to go twice a day
and you can pull this off
and you're great in front of the camera
and you need minimal editing,
I would even use the YouTube Live tool.
This is what I'm doing actually right now.
I'm recording this using
the YouTube Live tool
but it's not being broadcast live to you.
It's being broadcast as an unlisted video
and then my editor is going to pull this,
save it, mash it up, pull
out all the uhms and ahs
and I've been coughing like crazy,
if you guys haven't it 'cause I'm sick
and you don't want to hear that stuff
but (coughs), there's another one.
She's going to cut out all that stuff
and then put together a final video.
But you could do it as
a live video to unlisted
and then release that as a video
and it would do better
than if you released it
as a live video itself.
It sucks, it's just the way
YouTube's algorithm works.
I wish they change it.
I've been trying to figure out
a better live strategy for myself
and talk to all the YouTube guys
and unless you're in gaming,
there's no real major
application yet for live.
And that really sucks
but I'm working on trying
to figure something up.
Next up, Michael Jordan.
Michael Jordan, ladies and gentlemen.
Why you say this could apply
to other social media platforms?
Every social media
platform has an algorithm
and you just need to understand
how the algorithm works.
The posting three times a
day may not work everywhere.
I'm not saying posting three
times a day works to Twitter
or to Instagram or to
Facebook or to Snapchat.
You probably need to post
a lot more to be honest
if you look in the other platforms
but it's understanding
the platform's algorithm
so we will win within it
'cause you can win on on your talent
and you can win on your looks
and you can win on your message
as you can win in a whole
bunch of different things
but you can also win by being
worse at all of that stuff
and just understanding
how the algorithm works
for that social media network.
So, I know YouTube best.
I'm trying to share the
advice that's helping me
quickly build my YouTube channel
but you can use the same metrics
to figure out and deconstruct
how other social media networks work.
Facebook isn't a great example
because it's a paid platform right now
to try to get organic reach.
It's not the game in Facebook.
So let's go to Instagram.
Look at Instagram
and I don't have a major
presence on Instagram.
I haven't really focused a
lot of attention on Instagram.
So I've been looking at
what hashtags that I want to be a part of?
It's #culture on Instagram.
You have to pay really important
attention to the hashtags.
I'd be looking at how many times
should I be posting pictures.
Now I might posting a picture once a day,
twice a day, 10 times a day.
You could start by deconstructing
who are the people that you look up to
and respect on Instagram
and then see how often
they're doing it and then try.
And if someone's at five a
day, you start by matching that
and you say, hm, what
happens if I go to six a day?
What if I go to two a day
and then you look at a different series.
Okay, so I have one series
of motivational quotes,
another series that's pictures
and other series that's selfies, whatever
and then you see,
this series getting lots of attention,
this series is not, let's kill that one.
Okay we're going to kill that one,
let's put in a new one,
what's it going to be?
Hmm, we've got a brainstorm.
It's all the same stuff,
you're a content producer.
You're just playing a
slightly different algorithm
so each social media
platform functions on its own
but the methodology can
be applied to all of them.
I think the most important part
is just understanding
what are the key metrics
that we're chasing and
then optimize for that.
So for YouTube,
all I care about is
looking at the watch time
and looking at the subscriber growth.
And again, this is all within my mission.
I want to help a billion entrepreneurs.
I want to do it the right way.
It's all about believe, right?
I could get to a million
way faster by posting
the top 10 stupidest things
Steve Jobs ever did in his life.
Right?
The the top 10 arguments
between entrepreneurs, right?
That's not me, right?
It's not my one word.
It's not what I'm all about.
So within your value system, right?
Then you figure out the
most important metrics
for that social media
structure and you just attack.
Next up, Tubitus.
I was uploading one video per day
for like two months straight
and my views went from 10 per day
to a hundred views per day.
Imagine that.
Then I stopped for three
weeks because I had a test
and it started and I started
again three weeks ago
and now I'm on 80 views
per day and growing.
So it really works a lot.
Congratulations.
Keep going, keep doing it.
Now make those videos better.
Sara Makes Art.
I wish I could do daily videos
but I'm barely managing with two and three
edited videos a week.
I started to live stream on
most days that I don't upload
so at least I would have
activity on my channel
most days of the week.
Yeah, again I pay attention to,
are the live streams helping
your channel or hurting?
Look at the watch time on them,
look at the subscriber growth on them.
Are they leading to growth
to your channel or not?
The only danger is
sometimes the live streams,
as I did on my channel,
a lot of them were leading to flat
or negative subscriber growth
and so it's why I killed them
and move them to a different series.
Sorry, different channel.
This is important.
Three videos a week that are good
is better than five videos a
week or seven videos a week
where half of them are bad.
Right?
Like again, I said I wish I
could be at five video a day.
I'm not because I can't produce
five quality videos a day.
I keep testing these series with you guys
and a lot of them just
don't pass the mustard.
It's just not good enough,
you don't like them enough.
So, if you'd liked all my new series
and I could be at four videos
a day, five videos a day.
You don't like my new series as much
and so I'm constantly testing new stuff
to see if you like this one.
How about this one?
You guys liked this series?
How about this series?
And so, you want to be at at
least a video a day but good.
It's got to be good stuff
so don't just throw crap at the screen.
You Are Leaders.
What I'd like to know is
what exactly is the payoff
for having a million or
high number of subscribers
after busting ones but to create
that much content for YouTube,
what will one actually
get in dollars and cents?
A thousand dollars bi-weekly?
750 a week?
250 a day?
A hundred dollars an hour?
What are the analytics on that?
I wonder.
Compensation depends on how much you do,
kind of outside of YouTube.
If you're only focused on AdSense,
it's not a great business model
and you can really ramp up the numbers.
If you look at whatever you're making now,
whatever your CPM is.
I think for most channels
it's a dollar, 50 to 250,
something like that.
So you just ramp up the numbers
and that's what you're going to make.
It really depends on the niche again.
I met some people at ClamorCon
who had million subscriber plus channels
and they're still trying
to make a full-time living
and haven't hired anybody in their team.
And in my business, we've got eight people
on the YouTube side and I'm
not a million yet, right?
So it depends on,
some markets are easier to sell,
some have more interest from from brands
and have more advertising
dollars flowing into it
and some people are just
better entrepreneurs.
I started this from the
beginning as a business.
It's why I want all the
comments responded to.
You know these are our customers.
This is the people that we care about.
It's not just a hobby for me.
It would never was just the hobby.
It was okay, if we're going to do this,
it's this part of my business.
It's part of me making an
impact to help entrepreneurs.
So there's a lot of
factors that go into it.
Much more than just how many subscribers
that a YouTube channel has.
Next up, twominutetips.
Great analysis and thanks for sharing.
When you have a niche
that's fairly focused,
you do get to the end of
what there is to share.
I've seen a number of providers
in my category come to brick wall.
My challenge now to expand my content
while still making it
relevant to the niche.
There's got to always be ways to grow,
always there ways to learn.
At the beginning for any channel,
you're audience is going to
be mostly beginners, right?
For most businesses, you're
audience is going to be beginners
who want to learn something.
And they might learn the
basics really quickly.
You can do a couple things.
You can not just show them to how to's.
You can bring on questions
from an audience, right?
So somebody has a question down below,
you can always encourage
it from your audience
and then go and answer that question.
You could do a review of how
somebody is doing your thing.
I don't know what it is that you do
but you can do a review
how somebody is doing it
and get feedback and tips and advice.
You can try to tie it
to some local news story that's happening
or an international news
story that's happening.
You could try to bring in,
if you see a famous entrepreneur
or something that you look up to.
How they might do it,
what do you what do you think that,
how Steve Jobs would knit a sweater?
I don't know exactly
what you're doing again.
You could take requests
like if there's anything art-related,
make it like this.
Like can you make a
portrait of this person?
There's always room for creativity.
There is always, always,
always in any field,
any industry room for creativity.
As soon as you say you hit a brick wall,
that's your opportunity.
It's your opportunity to be more creative
and find another way
and that's going to be your
chance to bust through.
Next up, Eclectic Alu.
So refreshing.
This really makes sense.
I don't think I can upload once a day
but I appreciate honest advice
and having this as a goal is helpful.
Also thank you for telling
these sub for sub guys
to go make good content, haha.
Listen, this an honest approach.
I appreciate that.
Not everybody can go and
make one quality video a day
and that's fine.
You don't necessarily need to
go out and do it right now.
There's a lot of people who
want to start a business
which they could be in it full time
but you can't right now
because you have bills to pay
and you have a full-time job
and you're doing this in
the evenings and weekends.
That's understandable.
And it is realities of life.
It's just having it as the goal.
Like this is where I want to get to
and trying to work towards it.
If you see it as an impossibility
or you just reject it out of hand
then you're never going
to get there, right?
But if you see it as, okay,
that's where I want to be.
This is a new standard
that I have for myself.
This is what I'm going to work towards.
I'm going to get better at it.
You can.
When I made my first videos,
it took me two days to make one video.
Take a camera and I record
it and it would suck
and record it again and it would suck
and just two days to make that one video
just recording.
And now in front of a camera, I just talk
because of the repetition
you get better at anything.
Through the repetition you get better
and so what might seem crazy
to make one video a day now,
if you have that as your goal,
you'll find ways to make it happen.
Doesn't mean you need to
quit your full-time job
or make drastic life changes.
You'll find ways to get better.
You'll find hacks to help you improve.
As you do it more and more and more,
you will just get faster
and more efficient at it.
And so I love the openness
and the approach Eclectic Alu.
And if you can't do it right now
then it's fantastic to have that
as your goal for the future.
Alright guys, going to end it there.
Don't know how long it's been.
It's been a while.
My throat is burning.
Thank you for the love on the series.
If you have a question
you like me to answer
in the future version
of the How To Get To One Million series,
leave it down below in the comments.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
See you soon.